foreign
has gripped the Northeast Indian state
of Manipur Garfield is imposed after the
unrest have been relaxed in some areas
and authorities have urged people to
give peace a chance a high-level inquiry
will be conducted
to fix responsibility
on the persons and a group who
instigated the violence and the
government servant who
addicted responsibility
for years tensions have been simmering
between the cookie tribes and metis over
the distribution of resources such as
land protests over giving special status
to the majority metis proved to be the
Tipping Point that you
Claudia launcher filmmaker and activist
says mateys don't have the same rights
as other ethnic groups we are not
allowed to settle anywhere any in any
part of the state we have to confine
here our settlements and then when we
talk about it they said that you are
trying to exploit us it is not sure we
we want to have the uniform law we want
to have the same right
Hospital officials say hundreds of
people were injured in the violence and
many are still recovering some
neighboring states have begun evacuating
the students from Manipur but there are
calls for come we are hoping that things
will get returned to normalcy that the
central government will intervene and
that
both sides will resettle and then the
peace will rain and then uh we are so
hoping that the maripu government also
will take some Big Town
to bring about equal development to
bring about equal opportunities
Security Forces remain on the streets
and military officials say at least 23
000 people displaced by the fighting are
been housed on Army basis
Swifter rights activists say meaningful
dialogue is needed there needs to be not
just an all-party
series of conclaves and meetings but
also communities need to start talking
to each other there's been a complete
breakdown of communication and that has
to be restored in order to for peace to
to come about which is a sustainable
peace authorities say the situation is
under control but for many here peace
remains elusive